some consumer news for you now if you
feel like you're paying
more for everything well you're
absolutely right prices pushed higher
once again in may
capping off the biggest 12-month
inflation spike since the financial
crisis back
in 2008 so we're breaking it all down
for you
[Music]
plays with olvo and his son are cutting
tile for a remodeling project
the contractor says supplies are hard to
come by and about 40 percent more
expensive than pre-pandemic
i've never seen this before i'm in the
business for 35 years a new government
report finds prices on goods and
services
surged again in may and looking back
over the last 12 months
prices have risen 5 percent that's the
largest 12-month inflation spike
since 2008 it seems like it was easier
to
freeze the economy than it has been to
defrost the economy
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger says
increased consumer demand is battling it
out with a shortage of supplies
that's showing up in higher prices on
everyday products
she also points to the speed of the
economy's reopening
that's actually happening faster than
employers can find suitable workers
and that's causing wages to jump a
little bit and then that can also
lead to a vicious cycle where the
companies actually have to raise their
prices
in order to make the equation work
it's all leading to inflation which the
federal reserve predicted as part of the
pandemic recovery
they believe it will be temporary but
not everyone agrees
this has a lot of economists worried
that we are going to see a general rise
of inflation
for a while now maybe not just a few
months but maybe this could persist
longer well she recommends preparing for
unprecedented times by saving
more paying off your debt and maximizing
your retirement contributions